je remets au oui à ces qui attendait ce
mode a great man jallet de julien
j'avais deviné j'avais deviné que sa
lettre griezmann oui quand on en sort
elle voulait poser une question est ce
que tu vas chez le docteur ouais mais
j'y suis même allé aujourd'hui chez le
docteur et magie verre de temps en temps
chez le docteur c'est important qu'on
vérifier si tout le corps du malien
moyen du monde
mais oui c'est ça oui oui
[Musique]
moi ce que j'essaye de percer leur
apporter un un minimum de deux répliques
qui puisse passer entre guillemets 1h30
avec moi qu'ils puissent proposer les
toutes les questions qu'ils veulent je
dis réponse en 120 sans tabou c'est avec
grand plaisir vraiment leur faire passer
un moment agréable
[Musique]
il ya des fois où ça enfin ça criait
partout et on en disait plus personne
n'en pouvait on a dû mettre nos casques
de jeu ontv parce que on n'arrivait plus
trop à gérer et à un jour a pas vraiment
pouvoir me lever à dire c'est pas
possible ça n'arrive pas je suis là je
suis manu je ne je me relève tous les
matins et quoi qu'il en soit et là je me
suis dit il faut faire quelque chose
on attend d'une main je vais la saisir
et en fait ça a été la première fois je
faisais ma vie que je saisis une marée
manque
[Musique]
l'idée c'est de permettre à l'enfant en
situation de handicap d'avoir des actifs
et comme les autres à prendre son jeune
âge finalement d'être accueillis comme
n'importe quel enfant donc tous ces
lieux qui jalonnent la vie
habituellement de tout enfant et puis
surtout aussi de permettre à leurs
parents d'avoir accès comme tous les
autres parents à des modes d'accueil
qu'ils puissent continuer je dirais à
mener une vie la plus ordinaire possible
malgré le handicap de leur enfant et
notamment pouvoir continuer à travailler
tout simplement pouvoir bénéficier de
temps de répit de disponibilité aussi au
reste de la fratrie
[Musique]
regarde regarde regarde mon maillot
c'est mon maillot de 2 quand j'ai gagné
la coupe du monde avec toutes les
signatures des joueurs
ouais c'est lent ouais
attends je sais pas si on va voir celle
de griezmann tout à l'heure quand on lui
a dit vas faire un visio avec corentin
il est venu s'installer les pressions
montent en est vraiment je sais pas je
ne vendent pas eu de suite si les mâles
ont préféré aller monde mal à
l'injection là et c'est une relation qui
est extraordinaire parce que ça
m'apporte énormément un mois aussi parce
que j'apprends beaucoup
c'est pas les seuls comme djediat poser
des questions donc apprendre la vie la
vie d'un footballeur mais ah mais moi
aussi j'apprends beaucoup japon de leur
vie il ya vraiment une belle relation
humaine qui secret pendant sept heures
séparent et demi
[Musique]
c'était vraiment une révélation pour moi
de passe qu'une fois que j'ai accepté
c'était de l'ag tous demandé on a fait
les idiots on a commencé les visio avec
cours de licence et donc on a on s'est
inscrit à l'édition famille à d'autres
j'ai rencontré les familles que depuis
le début du confinement se voient tous
les vendredis soir on a mis en place un
suivi psychologique pour mon aîné livia
et la dernière est là qu il ya six ans
et demi à lui non une éducatrice aussi
qu'il a appelé pour les deux jours comme
ça il reste un mail au ciel et moi une
éducatrice qui m'appelle on avait
toutefois autre chose un moment donné
dans la semaine à faire que de
d'entendre de s'occuper d'eux ou du
frère ou de son nom de mon fils je
dirais que la plateforme de grandir
ensemble à sauver long confinement
parce que on était les cocottes minutes
en sifflant inconsciemment et que je
pense que si je n'avais pas saisi cette
mince y avait pas eu ces bouffées
d'oxygène par toutes ces visions on
avait vraiment l'impression d'aller vers
l'extérieur de communiquer avec des
personnes et de deux d'agrémenter de
choses positives nos journées un jeu je
ne sais pas où on aurait terminé en fait
où j'ai pu voir moi aussi quand j'étais
jeune que quand les personnes sont les
enfants sont handicapés familles et
c'est quelque chose à faire à faire
évoluer vraiment affaire à faire changer
c'est ce que je vais essayer de faire
encore en magasin avec eux et sur le
long terme